is there advice
from your life that you can give to
young people today
high school college you know about their
career
or maybe about life in general i'm not
like
a career coach by like because that's
right like i'm definitely not a life
coach i don't have it all figured out
but i think there's a um
there's a perpetual cycle of
um you know thinking that
there is a um there's kind of like a
template for success
right maybe there is but i in my
experience i haven't seen it right um
you know i would say people in high
school
right um so much of their focus
is on getting straight a's filling their
cv
with this and this and this so that it
looks impressive
right that that is not
i think a good way to optimize your life
right
do the thing that fills your life with
passion
do the thing that fills your life with
with interest and
you know do that perpetually right a
straight a student you know is really
impressive but also
you know somewhat boring right so so i
i think you know injection of more of
that kind of
um interest into into the lives of young
people
would go a long way in in just
both upping their level of happiness and
then just kind of
ensuring that looking forward they are
not
suffering from a can you know perpetual
condition
of oh i have to satisfy these like you
know check boxes
to to do well right because you can lose
yourself in that whole process
for the rest of your life but it's nice
if it's possible like max tegmark was
exceptionally good at this
at mit figure out how you can spend a
small
part of your percent of your efforts
that such that your cv looks really
impressive
yeah absolutely there's no like without
a doubt
like that's that's a baseline that you
need to have
um and then so like spend most of your
time doing like amazing things you're
passionate about
but such that it uh uh kind of like
planet nine produces
objects that uh that feed your cv
uh like slowly over time so getting good
grades in high school maybe doing
extracurricular activities
or or in terms of like you know for
programmers that's producing code that
you can show up on github
like leaving traces like um
throughout your efforts such that your
cv looks impressive to the rest of the
world
in fact i mean this is somewhat along
the lines of what i'm talking about
we see like getting like good grades is
important but
grades are not a tangible like product
like you cannot out you know show your
a and and have your a live a separate
life from you
code very much does right um music
very much takes on you know provided
somebody else listens to it right
right provide like takes on a life of
its own
that's kind of what i mean right doing
doing stuff that uh that can then
get separated from from you is is
exceptionally attractive right it's like
a it's like a fun
and uh and it's also very impressive to
others i think we're moving to a world
where grades mean less and less
like certifications mean less and less
if you look at
especially again in the computing fields
getting a degree finishing your
um currently just getting finishing your
degree whether it's bachelor's or
master's or phd
is less important than the things you've
actually put out into the world
right right and that's a fascinating
kind of that's a that's great that
in that sense the meritocracy is in its
richest most beautiful form is is
starting to win out
yeah it's weird because like uh you know
my understanding
and i'm not like i don't know the
history of science well enough to
to speak very confidently about this but
you know the
advisor of my advisor of my advisor
from undergrad uh like didn't have a phd
right so i think it was a more common
thing back in the day
even in uh the academic
sector to you know
not have you know faraday like faraday
didn't know algebra
when drew diagrams about you know
magnetic fields like
his faraday's law was derived entirely
from intuition
so uh it is interesting to how
the world of academia has evolved into a
you got to do this and then get phd then
you have to post doc once and twice
and maybe thrice and then like you you
move on so
you know it does i do wonder you know if
we're
you know if there's a better i think
we're heading there
but it's a fascinating historical
perspective like that we might have just
tried this whole thing out uh for a
while where we put a lot more emphasis
on grades and certificates and
um degrees and all those kinds of things
i think the difference
historically is like we can actually
using the internet show off the
show off ourselves and our creations
better and better and more effectively
whether that's code or producing videos
or all those kinds of things that's
right
you can become a certified drone pilot
that's true of all the of all the things
you want to pick yeah for sure
or you could just fly make youtube
videos against hundreds of thousands of
views with your drone and
never getting a certificate um that's
probably illegal don't do it
you